all right
it seems that we are
live and no technical problem this time
i was sure there was going to be one and
then uh then i took the time to make
sure that there wasn't but there
there was at the beginning i don't know
why youtube doesn't like my camera for
some reason all right okay
so there are a lot of things going on
first of all for those that are new or
just showing up the way this works is
people that support me on patreon
for like uh 10 or more they get to ask
questions in advance
and so i usually go through all the
questions
i've been able to go through all the
questions until now unless some
sometimes some questions i just i just
kind of skip over if they're not
appropriate if they're
if they're too long maybe but most of
the time i get through all the questions
and then
if people put in super chats then i will
look at those
when i'm done with all the questions so
that's the way it works
and uh i have a few announcements to
make
um i am going to be
for this is going to be like my first uh
trip
since the beginning of kovid i will be
speaking at
the uh european men's gathering
and uh it's the first week of august
this year in in in denmark
so it's in jutland in denmark you can
look up on the website it's called
manifesto.com but it's man like
m-a-n-i-p-h-e-s-t-o-manifesto.com
and uh and so yeah i'm gonna be speaking
there it's a wild bunch
you know they they have a whole mixture
of kinds of guys there
alexander bard who maybe you have seen
online is part of that group
uh andrew sweeney who i've had a
discussion with before
on my uh that i was on his channel
recently and uh
sorry a bunch of a bunch of other
other guys you know people from all
kinds of backgrounds all kinds of ideas
and so it's going to be wild but i'm
really excited to uh to have been
invited there i feel honored to be
invited there as well
um there's also an orthodox priest who
will be there who was there last year he
will be there as well
and so it's going to be like it's going
to be a pretty intense
kind of clash of the minds and and uh
laboratory for
exploring ideas and so i'm pretty
excited to go there so if you want to
sign up i'm sure there's still room
there you know especially with
coven and everything i'm sure they still
have room for people who are willing to
uh
to go to denmark and participate in that
so that's pretty exciting i
am still working hard on my new website
i've slowed down a little bit just
because i've been able to have
the the branding and the logo
done by an amazing artist her name is
heather pollington you can look her up
online
she's actually the one who's doing the
costumes for the new lord of the rings
series
um and so sorry that she's really
amazing
and so i'm working with her on my logo
and she's going to help with some of the
branding
uh so all of that is kind of coming
together today
i got the new audio for the opening of
my
of my video if you uh if you notice on
my recent videos i didn't have any
musical opening
that's because i've been having
copyright problems with
uh i mean obviously not with the corsica
of uh
music but with the recording which is a
recording from the 30s or 40s
but nonetheless i've been kind of uh
caught like copyright uh warnings on my
channel have been appearing and
from different sources so it would be
such a rabbit hole to kind of go down
there and try to figure out who actually
owns the copyright and
who's who's doing a false claim and then
try to get the rights for it
so i'm very very fortunate that there's
a musician friend of mine
his name is matthew wilkinson matthew is
a great guy
i spent about a month at his house a few
years ago
carving a tombstone there that in
charleston and uh we really we really
hit it off
it was a lot of fun staying with him and
his wife
and um so matthew is a professional
organist and he recorded
he rearranged the pascal
hymn and he re-recorded it with piano
and violin
and matthew is actually is actually
someone who probably has a little thing
on me because
when i was at his house we would spend
evenings talking and talking and once in
a while we'd have a few beers
and one time he had a few beers in me
and uh
he he he asked me if i could do the
symbolism of anything
and i said sure everything is symbolic
so we can do the symbolism of anything
and so he asked me if i would if i would
describe the symbolism
of flatulence and he did record me while
i was giving that explanation
and i made him promise he would never
reveal that uh recording to anybody
but anyway so that's just a funny thing
about matthew so i'm gonna play for you
now
the uh new intro for my channel so i'm
really excited
so i i hope this will go through the
microphone well here we go um
[Music]
so there you go so what do you think i'm
really curious to know what people think
i'm actually looking at the chat for
once in my life
i'm looking at the chat so give me your
comments if you would
how you feel it's a little more
nostalgic than uh
than what i had before there's a little
bit of sadness in it but i like that i
kind of like that because
you know the paschal hymn is about the
resurrection but uh there is something
about our moment right now which le
as someone said mike lagrive says it's
sour sweet
and i think that's exactly the that's
the feeling that i'm happy that is
being captured because there's something
about our moment right now which is sour
sweet
we see this possibility kind of growing
a positive possibility but also
surrounded by a lot of darkness and so
hopefully
this will be yeah hopefully people will
will uh
will appreciate it so i'm pretty excited
about that so there's a lot of good
stuff going on
today i don't know if it happened but
today i think we reach
uh 10 000 subscribers on my clips
channel so if you're not subscribed to
the clip channel
you need to go do that and that uh that
clip channel has just been great
it's been run by lisa parrott who you've
seen in the
in the chat probably and uh la say
anderson
who has also been involved there's a few
other people that were involved but they
were the mo
they're the most that are involved uh
kind of um let's say headed by lisa
and uh and so it's it's just been great
to uh
to see people kind of take my ideas and
and uh
and it's it's been great for me to see
what kind of questions
people care about and uh you know you
know what kind of
what kind of videos come out of the clip
channel because i don't direct it it
just
they just decide what they want to do
and they put them up uh as they want to
so
so yeah all right so gabe larocque says
that my intro needs a touch of metal
hmm interesting if you record a metal
version of my opening gabe
i will play it i will find a good
a good uh subject for the video and i
will play it so
so uh yeah everybody needs to to get it
done
how about this if you record a quality
version in the different styles of the
the the pascal hymn if it's quality then
i'll try to figure out a time to uh a
subject in which to play it you know
and probably i'm opening up a whole can
of worms here but um
but uh but yeah all right so last
announcement before i get into the
questions
is that uh tomorrow
no in two days and two days is my is my
birthday and
my wife is amazing and she surprised me
with a surprise thing i don't know
exactly what it is
but my the whole family were leaving for
a few days uh for some surprise thing
uh which means that i i had really
planned to do
the patron only video today and but
everything was kind of compressed and
compressed and compressed and i finally
actually did it but then then you know
technical idiot i am for some reason
it didn't record i don't know what
happened you know as usual
so i didn't have the nerve to do it
again but i will as soon as i get back
means first week of july i will put out
the patreon only video which is going to
be
on uh all these weird things that are
coming up this
vid um series on netflix
and also the uh what is it called sexy
beasts
and all of these weird things these all
these weird narratives that are
appearing
i'm going to talk a little bit about
that you know and kind of the invasion
of hybrids and what that
what that means so um all right so here
we go let's go
into the
let's go into the uh questions
all right let's start with the website
it is super hot here i know it's hot in
a lot of places but
man today was a tough one
um okay so here we go let's start with
the grubmeister
asks i recently saw a map that showed
ufo sightings are overwhelmingly in
america western europe and australia
other parts of the world have a much
much lower number of sightings
what is that what it what is it that
predisposes people
in these countries to see ufos i have a
feeling it has something to do with an
inability to see
organic link between spirit and body as
a result
of living in a highly materialistic
society but i'm interested in your
thoughts
and so i would say that i would say that
you could describe it in two ways
i would say that there are secondary
causes the secondary causes probably
have a lot to do with the fact that we
live
in a extremely technical society
in which we have replaced the
the lights in the sky with all kinds of
other lights you know with
their satellites planes all these things
kind of uh
going around and probably some things we
don't know about obviously some
especially in america there are probably
some secret vessels
that nobody knows about uh and so
because of that
they're a lot more ufo sightings that's
one of the reasons
the other one of the other reason is
probably a more kind of mythological
reason
and it has to do with it has to do with
the relationship between
aliens and uh the kind of the end of
a world you know if you want to
understand that the
one of the one of the best people that
has actually put that in in a narrative
form
is in the movie apocalypto where you see
the you know you see the at the end of
the movie you see the spanish ships
on the horizon appearing and when by the
time they shake the hands
of the spaniards you know that their
world is over
and so this is something which i think
has different layers of
manifestation but ufos seem to
participate in that same
in that same um in that same phenomena
so you could understand it as
the fact that you have unidentified
stars
and so unidentified principalities are
kind of appearing all over the place
these strange principalities are
re-manifesting themselves
and so and it's kind of like this flood
of
this lack of cohesion appearing as all
these gods appearing on the horizon
whether whether you it doesn't matter
what the material causes
it's just happening in that way and
through all kinds of means whether it's
all the people taking psychedelics
whether it's people wanting to
re-embrace
pagan old pagan religions whether it is
people
who worship science all of these things
are all related
if you understand kind of the symbolism
of the book of enoch
and the all the traditions that are in
there so
it's not a good sign that's for sure
when we're flooded with ufos and ufo
sightings it's not a good sign
uh yeah and short answer is there are
more demons just more demons
in the u.s and other places right now
sorry i don't want to like bash not just
the us but just like in the west let's
say
you know the flood gates are open this
is the best way to understand that so
yeah uh yeah dr
drag brecker says the stranger so yeah
indeed that's it it's so it's but it's
just a different levels of reality the
idea that the stranger is kind of
flooding in it
you don't have to take it only at the
political level you have to kind of
understand it in terms of ideas in terms
of technology in terms of
of uh of la of breakdown of identities
all of this is kind of happening
all at the same time so exactly
all right so let's continue i think if i
take too much time i need each of these
questions it's going to go on forever so
i'm in a weird mood too man
when i get in this mood it gets strange
all right so pneuma asks how should we
understand the nature of tradition
it appears to be a part of the body of
christ's participation
with that which was handed down from the
apostles in scripture
keeping in mind that not all things that
come to be traditions are equal in
status yes
i also can see that tradition helps us
connect to the past and helps us
not rely on our understanding of things
but i also see a danger in that too
those who came before us could set a bad
precedent future generations could build
on top of that
or something that gets integrated as a
tradition that should not have been
is accepted i know a lot of times bad
ideas can be weeded out but it's not
automatic and bad ideas
can still linger for a long time too so
yes you're absolutely right
and so the best way to kind of
understand that is to understand
that ultimately the church or the body
of christ
has a
has a kind of natural mechanism by which
it will
it will integrate certain things and
will kind of cast out
other things and it's going to happen
organically it's messy but it's not it's
not
uh it still happens the best text to
understand
kind of tradition is really a text by
vladimirlovsky which i've recommended
several times called tradition and
traditions you can find it online
a pdf of it and it really kind of shows
how tradition that which is handed to us
which is the idea of understanding what
tradition is that which is handed to us
is is a very inclusive term and includes
scripture and so
when we say something like scripture is
part of tradition we just mean
we have to understand it as that which
has been handed to us because
the reason why we trust scripture is
because it has been handed to us to a
certain extent
or at least the reason why we attend to
it in the first place
so so of course scripture has its own
validity that you can
switch a certain level that you can that
you can discover and and the richness
you can discover reading it
but the fact that we give it authority
in the first place is because it has
been handed
down to us by those that we those people
that we trust and those people that
we see kind of in line uh behind us
between us and christ
so so that's the that's the best way to
understand it so
so there are different types of
tradition different levels of tradition
but ultimately
tradition is also just a way of seeing
the world
and it has to do with what people
sometimes call the mind of the fathers
and so it's kind of a a lens by which to
view reality
and so i think it's easier to understand
that today
um so so yeah
um
all right so nelson justin evans asked
what is the symbolism of malicious
compliance malicious compliance means
being obsequious
to show flaws in leadership of others
malicious compliance i don't think i've
ever heard that term before
um
people conforming to the letter but not
the spirit of a request
okay by strictly following orders of
superior while knowing or intending that
compliance with the orders will have an
unintended or negative
consequence okay so that's the idea so
the idea is
it's you fall you basically follow the
rule to the letter
knowing that by doing so you will
actually cause harm right
and so um like what is a symbol of
malicious compliance i mean it is it's
something like uh
it's something like uh a death like when
christ talks about
what you know with the idea that that
the sp that the spirit is living but the
letter is dead
and so that's an example where it's
where you know if you
if you try to follow the letter
then you can actually twist it and you
can kind of
turn it towards something which is which
is false i
talked about this before where like
reality is actually held
up from above it's not held from below i
know that for
a lot of kind of science scientific
types this is going to sound frustrating
but below down here is variability and
and uh
and fluctuation and and uh you know
um and idiosyncrasy and so it's like
you could read a law or you could you
could read take something and
be extremely idiosyncratic in the way
that you
interpret it and it can be actually
accurate based on
on the the text let's say of the law uh
but it becomes a way to actually
to destroy to destroy the to destroy the
body to destroy the being so
you know uh it's like white-washed tune
right that's what christ calls
calls that kind of uh that kind of
behavior
so timothy aspesla asks hey jonathan i
love how pleasant islamic geometric
patterns look
um and i've seen pictures of churches
where they are being used i'm fond of
the idea that we can properly integrate
this artistic tradition but i don't know
how to read them
what's the meaning of these patterns and
so i mean the meaning they're patterns
they're really
kind of pure patterns and so they
depends on which pattern
but you know the way that you encounter
a pattern or a
shape will also will will will depend on
what it is and sometimes it's not a it's
not necessarily a narrative
meaning it's more it's like it's it's a
structural meaning or a structural
uh pattern and then sometimes it can be
applied to narrative
structure so it really just depends on
the pattern but uh i agree
like for me one of my favorite times or
artistic moments in history is what we
call the normand
the the norm in sicily where the normand
were kings and sicily but they were also
very close to the byzantines
and at the same time had very good
relationship with uh
with uh with with uh with muslims that
were in northern africa and so if you
look at those churches like the church
in palermo or the church in cefalu
you have these amazing synthesis of
christian
architecture with islamic mosaics and
then beautiful
christian christian mosaics as well of
images and stuff and so yeah i agree i
think that there
there are ways to kind of integrate
these things that could be really
powerful
all right so luca azkovic says what is
holy anger in your video about prince
yvonne and the grey wolf prince yvonne's
mouth gets
mount gets eaten by the grey wolf but
then the gray wolf becomes his mount
yvonne's tame body was replaced by a
wild body which is more powerful but
also more dangerous to ivan
and that's when you mentioned holy anger
can you elaborate more on it
what is it who had it and what are the
examples of it
and so i mean holy anger can be
manifested at moments when
the integrity of uh
the integrity of an important body is in
danger
you know and so there there is a way in
which for example
you can how can i say this there's a way
in which
you can self-sacrifice and that is the
highest
form of virtue but there's also a way in
which you can defend the weak
and that is also a very high level of
virtue and spiritual
manifestation and so you know a soldier
who will defend
the the defend a noble cause or defend a
weak can manifest
holy anger in in seeing something which
is beautiful something which has
integrity
something which is which has coherence
be destroyed by
by people with with bad intentions and
so
i think that in scripture you see you
see examples of that and it mostly has
to do
with uh kind of de-sacralization in
scripture especially
you know when you know when somebody
profanes
something holy then there's like a holy
anger which manifests itself and then
tries to
to cohere that holy place and prevent
it from being from being from dissolving
into the into the world and so
so that's how i see holy anger i mean
holy anger is a
is a is kind of an extreme way to
to to stop the world from being
completely destroyed
so yeah
okay so josh the mover asks
can you discuss the symbolic
relationship between
oil and blood
also any plans to chat with father
celiwan justiniano i haven't seen him
making the rounds on some other podcasts
um and so can you discuss relationship
between
oil and blood and so it's it's difficult
to what you mean like do you mean if you
mean something like
like oil like oil for example for
anointing
and then blood maybe so if it's
something like that
then i would say that oil is more
related to to
how can i say this oil is more related
to kind of naming in the sense of like
uh
showing what is what is
true so it's like it might like liquid
light if you want like
liquid light coming down from above and
so you anoint a king
you how you anoint a person you anoint
uh
the pillar like jacob anoints the pillar
in the in
you know when he has the dream of the of
the latter so
imagine like liquid light which is kind
of coming down and
and showing where the light falls right
and so you imagine the person
has oil on their forehead they're shiny
you know they're for they're reflecting
light
and so and then blood has more to do
with covering
it so it's more like that it's more like
a kind of kind of covering
uh and uh and also obviously it's
related to to a form of purification
um and so that's as that's as close as i
can get you know
as for father siloan i would love to
have father silhouette
on my channel i would very much love
that to happen
so all right so c main
says
what is the symbolism of naming after
something children
cities and places are often named after
an inferential person a saint or an
event occasionally it is reversed a
child is named after a city
or place we now see traditional or
classic children's names being replaced
with trendier names that's connected to
something
neighborhoods and streets are sometimes
named after an influential person in the
community schools business
theories movements etc often named after
people
typically the person who was the first
in the domain exactly or
who inspired the domain so you already
kind of have your answer in the question
it has to do with principality it has to
do with the idea of becoming
the the head of something becoming
the origin the head these things are
very much related and so the origin and
the head of things
are is is very related and so it's like
the point that unites
certain so imagine it's like you you
have a point that unites certain things
together
and you want especially if you name
something based on a founder
or or someone who's important in a field
you realize that that person becomes
like an axis around that field turns
and so you want to name a laboratory
after an important scientist or some
cure or whatever you know because you
realize that that person is already
a point of culmination of meaning in
being an
origin of a field or something like that
now in terms of naming cities after
people it mostly has to do with it with
with a kind of recognizing of
that which we model right we model these
people and so we name
things after those that we model and
that is actually how
principality works that's how that's how
these heads and bodies that kind of lay
up
that layer themselves in the world
that's how it it functions
um so so i hope that makes sense and the
idea that right now people are naming
their kids after
like meaningless names they just put
they try to find the most random thing
to like name their names uh or just
sounds that
sound nice uh yeah it's a nice that's a
nice sign a breakdown if you want to
know
it's like it's it means that we have
nothing that we all look towards
nothing that we all uh look to you know
so you can imagine it like even
let's say in terms of a smaller scale
the idea of like naming someone after
your father
or naming someone after your mother
naming one of your kids after your
father
um you know that's the kind of thing
where it creates this line
of or this order of principality um
and it it binds you together closer it
binds it
creates cohesion it actually works that
way um
all right so from mikhail what is the
symbolism of mermaids
anderson's little mermaid not the disney
one had a vibe of a confused angel
attempted to join himself with a man
that would produce giants but instead
sacrificing herself and becoming a
proper
angel disney flipped it upside down yeah
in western christianity mermaids seem a
bit like cherubs guarding cities like
copenhagen and warsaw germans
even had a weird story of a bishop fish
from the baltic sea blessing the king of
poland
with the sign of cross so mermaids are
just hybrids that's what they are
they're hybrids they represent
the edge the edge of uh of the world
they're like other hybrids like centaurs
and
and uh satires and all these kind of
hybrid creatures that live in the forest
but now in terms of
uh the water there were these these
hybrid
fish man you know uh uh hybrids and so
they become
so you can understand them you know
as becoming the object of of desire
you know like they become erotic figures
because they are the strange woman like
in an extreme way
you know it's like people like all those
all those freaks on
i'm going to say this all the 4chan
types with their cat ladies it's like
there's something about the there's
something about the hybrid of the
on the edge which is which is attractive
um but it's also it's so it represents
also in this at the same time it
represents kind of
inaccessible potential right and so
obviously you you're not you can't
that's one of the ideas of uh
let's say anderson's little mermaid is
that you can't cross these ontological
levels like
you to do so is to is
is dangerous right it it is it creates
a problem so in terms of of the little
mermaid it's not exactly the same as the
the angels and um and humans it has more
to do with something lower right
more some something like uh
something more like hybrid animals
something like uh
to you know sweet tooth and all that
kind of stuff it has more to do with
that
you know and so it's like this idea that
identity would would kind of dissolve
but
yeah in terms of the the anderson i'm
not sure i'm not sure
that his symbolism is is the proper one
i don't know what to tell you and
i'm not that big a fan of of uh
anderson's uh
fairy tales to be honest it seems like
in his fairy tale it has to do with
something like uh
class culture where you know the idea is
like know your place right you can't
move from where you are
almost like a caste system where if you
try to pretend you're something you're
not
then it's going to split you in half
it's going to
it's going to cause you pain and all of
that which is not completely
false but it's also yeah
it's definitely not like the christian
idea let's say of uh
of uh and i think also like she he
actually changed the ending of his
tale if i remember correctly the first
one he had she just kind of dissolves
and becomes seafoam
and then and then people didn't like
that so if my understanding is that he
changed the ending to make it more
kind of uh make it look kind of like you
said like that she now she's kind of
brought up into heaven or whatever
all right all right so goof asks
is the act of creation a type of
precursor of the fall
it would seem to me that creating heaven
and earth is a move towards multiplicity
and at this higher level does not yet
denote a negative connotation however it
appears
that this move to multiplicity is the
pattern that can
or does become a fall at lower levels of
being the act of creation seems to
destroy a unity or oneness
in a way not with the trinity but in
turn
releases everything it creates the other
typing it route right now i realized
that this would make
an act of creation the act of creation
sacrificial the first sacrifice
maybe that is why sacrifice is baked
into reality sorry i'm rambling
i would very much appreciate your
thoughts on that so yeah so
the idea is that is that this is this is
a really important question it's a very
important question because it's one it's
the reason why everybody loves
gnosticism again
because people struggle to kind of
understand
reality as the union of love
and to understand that unity does not
preclude
multiplicity multiplicity is
gathered within unity it exists
potentially in unity and it can exist
even
explicitly you know let's say out
of unity but remaining within unity if
it remembers the one
so the multiple that remembers the one
is participating in the unity
of the one it's actually participating
in in its in its
in its unity and so saying ephraim the
syrian has one of the most beautiful
images of that where he says
you know the saints the saints
they come down the mountain of paradise
and then they walk on the water of the
ocean
and so in in this image it's as if all
of this multiplicity now
is is positive it's like it all has this
kind of positive
uh beauty it's like it's the glory of
god right it's not
it's not at all a fall it's like the
creation then becomes the glory of
of the infinite in its multiplicity and
so
that's what you would say would be the
positive aspect of that
and when when multiplicity
wants to have let's say wants to exist
on its own
that's when you experience the fall
but there's that's the mystery that i've
been trying to point you guys to this
mystery which is
a very very deep deep deep and difficult
mystery
which is that there's something about
death
which it's like if you were able to
experience death in the right way
in christ let's say then that death
itself would be glory would be chained
when i say i say changed into glory
it's not just not changed in the sense
that it becomes
something else right it's change in the
sense that
the very meaning of death is now
exposed in the light of
of christ and it becomes glory
so
anyways
talking about that kind of stuff is
probably not very useful all right so
here we go
so uh so v sac 2008 i think this is
chris
albano says blessed feed the pentecost
jonathan i've been
reading exodus lately and i admit always
struggling with the plagues of egypt i
know it's a big topic but i was reading
the one on hail today
could you share any insights on that one
there are a few things i noticed first
for this plague pharaoh's servants hear
the warning and act to save themselves
in their household by taking refuge in
their houses
second once moses raises his staff
there's thunder and hail and very
interestingly a fire
passes on the earth finally there's a
focus on damaging things in the fields
especially
structure bearing things men animal
grass and
field trees are mentioned thank you so
so the best way i think to understand
this it has to do with this
this kind of uh these kind of opposites
and so you can understand that it's
i mean first of all just the idea of
like water
of like destructive water coming from
above or like this hard water that's
coming from
above and then then also fire at the
same time so it's like there's hail and
fire
at the same time which seems like a
complete contradiction but you also
understand it if you understand it
exactly as that
that's kind of the two opposites
happening at the same time
rather than the opposites alternating
with each other so here's a good example
of
of another way of seeing this where in
when the the hebrews leave egypt
then what they have they have
alternating fire and water
so during the day there's a column of
of of water a column of of a
cloud and then during the night there's
a column of fire
so they follow the column of fire during
the night and they follow the column
of water during the day so you can
understand it like no matter how you
the totality of its meaning you can you
can
understand it as this alternating
reality like a motor right
so it's it's like the day you know the
hot day
is led by the cool water
and the cool night is led by the hot
flame and so
think of it as a yin yang symbol if that
that's useful to you you have
like the white with the black dot and
the black with the white dot
the opposites are led by their other and
this is what is making the cycle
turn properly let's say but then when
there's a confusion
and then both happen at the same time
then that is when
it it causes a breakdown and so this is
actually probably a really good time to
understand that
you know the idea that it's like fire
and water at the same time like
think of our day think of our age where
you both have
the most intense level of control that
has ever existed
you know police state that has ever
existed in the history of humanity with
with with the with the most control and
quantification and
calculation that has ever existed and at
the same time this sense that we live in
a constant carnival and that
anything goes and then anything can
happen and so it's like the beast
and the [ __ ] together right they're
just they're they're
somehow they shouldn't be together but
they're together and so this is
this image of let's say hail and fire at
the same time at least that's my
my kind of understanding of that um
so i think that the fact that it
destroys things in fields
or it destroys trees especially has to
do with this breakdown the breakdown of
of uh of the world destroying the
structures it's destroying the things
that are holding them together
um and so yeah and said maybe you're
going the taking refuge in the house and
taking your animals into the house with
you
is like an image of the ark i would
imagine so
that's the best way that i can
understand that anyways
those are hard i mean they're hard to
understand those kinds of
things in scripture
all right so cs street soul says about a
month ago a castle which is purported to
the basis
of count dracula's castle made in
international news by giving free
vaccines
sorry the castle made advert signs and
masks where the victims syringe
the vaccine syringe were the vampire
fangs
this is hard to believe the castle also
offered a free tour of their torture
exhibit
if and when you got the vaccine from
them what are your thoughts
about this event is this an example of
symbolism happens i would say
yeah it definitely is
i mean is it really a necessity to uh
to say what this means like or what what
is going on here
um
yeah you will be a slave of the vampire
i don't know what to tell you
you know that movie there are like those
are those early early versions and
vampire movies like of of uh
of of actually uh bram stoker's dracula
where you would
you would see the woman you know with
the pale eyes who'd become just a
slave to the vampire and does all his
will
yeah that's right
all right becky baumgardner asks says
in your conversation with richard
rowland you characterize the us as
babylon
and the u.s west coast as the ultimate
margin born and raised in the seattle
area i can attest to the freakish
strength of the principalities here
can you discuss what role the us west
coast might be playing in the strange
apocalyptic time we live in
so if this is actually an opportunity
for me because someone wrote me
uh i forget his name sorry i forgot your
name but someone wrote me
also um in private and and it was
someone who
was a member of the military and who had
spent many of his life
much of his life defending his country
and
he was a little bit taken aback uh to
the fact that i
said that the united states is the [ __ ]
in in
revelation and i understand that i
actually i felt sympathetic because as
soon as i
said that i regretted it like i was you
know it's one of those things where
you say it it's too late and then you
kind of regret it a little bit
because i feel like it was too easy for
me to just say it that way
um but that i probably should have been
able to explain it a little more
and the us is the edge of the world and
if you want to understand the west coast
it's the edge of the edge of the world
it's the end of it's the western
point in civilization it's the place
where the sun goes down
california is the end of the world folks
i know what to tell you
right so i can use the image of
california maybe as an example
of why i think
why i said that you know and and i
probably don't even have to tell you
you know what california is like
everything that it's related to in terms
of
hollywood in terms of music
entertainment yeah pornography
all of that it's all california right
and so but there's something else going
on and this is also
the the the something else going on in
the united states as well
which is that i also believe that
just like in revelation
i'm going to tell you something here
that i've never said i guess maybe
publicly
so in revelation the best way to
understand it is that
the beast the [ __ ]
and the new jerusalem they're
all images of the city they're all
images of rome you could say
there there's something of rome in all
of those three
and the idea that rome becomes christian
and something like the founding of
constantinople where it's the first
christian the great christian
city becomes an image a little image of
this new jerusalem and so it's not the
new jerusalem but it's like an it's like
an image a fractal image
of of this change this
this kind of beast killing the [ __ ] if
you can imagine someone like diocletian
right clamping down on the roman
decadence
and then and then after that you have
this change
where you have a conversion and then
finally
the the the arrival of christian rome
and the
founding of constantinople so i think
that the in the united states
something like that is going to happen
as well
that the united states is not just the
[ __ ] but is in a way
the horde the beast and possibly the
place
or the the the potential out of which
something like the new jerusalem will
occur and you can already kind of see it
because you can see that
on the one hand christianity
is dying and most visibly attacked
you know uh at least ideologically right
now in the united states but it's also
the place where it still has
one of the strongest bastion and one of
the most authentic bastions
and uh and so someone in the uh someone
in the chat is mentioning sarah from
father sarah from rose so yeah
father sarah from rose and his monastery
are in california too
and in california you have everything
you have all the worst and you have all
the best
and that's the strangeness of the end
that's the strangeness of the
of the this final moment where you can't
completely separate the wheat from the
tares
and you know that it takes christ to
return let's say
in order to do that and to and to be
able to separate
uh one from the other and so hopefully
that will help
to at least mitigate a little bit of my
comment about the united states
um but i for sure i think the united
states is going to play one of the most
important roles and how
all of this moment plays out like all of
this
whatever it is breakdown whatever it is
it's going to happen
it's going to happen in the u.s guys a
lot of it's gonna happen there
okay so yeah
okay so let me give you an example for
example of the difference
so imagine a [ __ ] right so a [ __ ] is
horror is a place where all the nations
come onto this
you know all the she she shares her body
with all the nations
and so she's not she doesn't
discriminate she just she trades with
all the nation that's the [ __ ]
right and so she she's completely she's
full of wasted seed of everybody
right and so that's that's what the
[ __ ] is sorry
it sounds explicit and everything but
it'll help you to understand
right and so that's the the [ __ ] it's a
place of mixture right
where all the all the seeds just kind of
mix in her
right and so but then there's the image
of the new jerusalem
and the image of the new jerusalem it
says in that image read it in scripture
it says that
all the glory of all the nations will be
gathered into
the city so what's the difference
what's the difference between the [ __ ]
which is the place of
mixture and breakdown of identity and
the and the the the new jerusalem
which is the place where all the glory
of the nations get gathered into one
place
and so it's the difference between
mixture and synthesis it's the
difference between
chaos and hybrid and
a kind of synthesis which gathers all
things into them hierarchically
right and so you can imagine that the
the neutralism is above
and gathers all the best things of the
city into itself
right and so it's the opposite of a
[ __ ]
but you can understand how they're
related because they're opposites
and the idea that one can flip and
become the other that rome can become
constantinople right that that's
part of that's part of the mystery
of of christianity so
so yeah so sorry symbolic means symbolic
means says i'm on no fap
i'm not gonna i'm gonna not gonna
imagine a [ __ ] sorry about that if i'm
if i cause you to sin i am very sorry
that's not that's not my purpose i
just want you to understand this because
it is important like it is important to
understand the difference between
mixture
and synthesis if you if there's a
problem right now
in the world it's that people can't tell
the difference
between a hybrid and a truly synthetic
being
you know all right
okay here we go
so keenan cronin says as our churches
start to stray by bringing in foreign
gods we're denying christ we're gently
following the judas pattern
what is the right thing for a
parishioner to do man it's just tough
some people online seem to recommend
changing church for a better one but
that feels like a revolutionary move
should we try to save our churches by
appealing to the leadership or
or could there come a time where someone
might need to leave their church to find
a new one
yes there is a time where you need to
leave your church to find a new one i'm
sorry to say this
you know and you should follow what it
says in scripture
you should you should now the difference
is that this is important
so you don't want to leave to start your
own
church if you're doing that you're wrong
like you're completely off
right but there is a point where things
break down so bad that you need to
reattach yourself to something but you
need to reattach yourself to something
that has
authority that's not just made up it's
not just you know
and so sometimes it can mean that you
can just leave a parish to go to another
parish it doesn't mean that you have to
leave
the whole thing right you can just try
to try to identify
uh priests pastors that are
coherent that aren't completely
swallowed up by this madness
and attach yourself to them and so you
know i know
it's hard it's it's a hard moment guys
it's a
it's a tough moment um so
i would say follow what it says in
scripture if you if you have a priest or
if you have some
your pastor or the person who is
responsible for you if they're saying
insane crazy things you should go to
them and you should tell them
what it is that's a problem and
and if they if they shrug you off if
they don't take what you're saying
seriously
then you have to then you have to go up
you should write to the bishop you
should you should go to whoever
is above that person and then you should
talk to them
and if if not if all if if you find
poison all along that line if you find
corruption all
around and
yeah then you need to find you need to
find someone
you need to find another body i mean
i'm saying these things and it just
sounds horrible but
this is not an easy time and it's going
to be messy and it's going to it's going
to cost you
something it's not going to be cheap
it's going to cost you
and it and it's going to be painful but
uh
sometimes it's necessary i'm not saying
i'm not i'm not
don't use me as an example like don't go
to your your priest or whatever and tell
them that jonathan said that i should
leave the church because that's not what
i'm saying
saying you should take it very seriously
and you should approach it carefully
but sometimes the world is there's a lot
of rot
right now around us and we need to we
don't want to
we don't want to uh to subject ourselves
to uh
to something which is completely rotten
like if you're in a liturgical church
there's there's there's some hope for
you in the sense that
if the priest if the priest is saying
stupid things but he's doing the liturgy
and his
and is is accomplishing the sacraments
in a straight
you know upright way then already it's
not
you you should be careful to leave
because the sacraments are proper and
the liturgy is doing its role
and you can still worship because the
things that are being said are are right
but it's harder if you're in a church
where everything depends on the pastor
and so and so it's like the pastor
basically decides the tone of everything
that's going to happen
then that makes it more more difficult
you know
yeah all right so phil says jonathan i
enjoyed the symbolic world episodes on
sergey
sir wayne in the green knight i wonder
if you've seen the trainer trailer for
the latest film adaptation
yeah i did see so what are your thoughts
on reviving this tale
as another big budget movie at this
point in time
assuming it is true to the story does it
point sorry
does it point towards a renewed interest
in the symbolic
um maybe i think it's possible it
depends
how it plays out it's almost impossible
to know
it's almost impossible to know how it's
going to play out now
the world is so topsy-turvy that they
could make this they could
they people are when you see an ad for
like a traditional story
being shown in a movie or in a new
version of a novel or whatever
it can be really bad because it can be
just another
desire to subvert it and to kind of
infect it with these
viruses that are going around and so
we'll see
i'm looking forward to seeing it it
looks powerful like it looks like it's
actually kind of
following you know it has a kind of
mythological
sheen to it when you look at it there's
something about it which seems to be
trying to be almost kind of operatic in
its visuals and so
i'm looking forward to it um and hope
that it's going to be uh
that it's going to be straight but
i could probably bet that he's going to
sleep with the with the wife of the
of the guy in the castle there's no room
for chastity in our world but if he
doesn't then i will
applaud and i'll say thank you thank you
for
for some you know a hint of
of of straight of straight thinkings in
the world
all right so david flores says most
traditional legends that heroes riding
horses lions griffins wolves but in your
recent
revelations video realized the [ __ ]
babylon is writing is a writer
mounted upon a dragon indeed how does
the mount influence the characteristic
of the writer
and so indeed you can understand the the
mount as
a kind of as an expression of the writer
and so think of it um a good example is
of course the cherub so you can imagine
the in the psalms it talks about how the
how god is writing
the cherub across the sky and so think
of it now so imagine god is riding the
cherub across the sky
and then now think of christ in his
glory with the four
beasts of ezekiel who are also the four
evangelists
that are manifesting him and so that's a
good example and so
you could imagine that that christ's
chariot
is the gospels right christ's mount
is the gospels it's scripture it's the
material
substrate that carries his message
that carries his story into into the
future
and so that so then the the idea is that
yes there will be a relationship the
mount will be an expression
of the writer um a good actually a
really good
a movie that gets that really well is uh
how to train your dragon
they get that they actually get it very
well they treat the dragon and how to
train your dragon
as a as an expression of the person
as a a kind of almost animal version
you know like kind of like the more
animal side of the person
which is being which is being uh
controlled or
directed by the writer and so so how to
train your dragon do it really well
um yeah and then
but then it becomes really weird because
they make it really clear that that's
what's going on like some of the dragons
even like
physically resemble their their their
writers if you if you look at the other
people in the uh
in the vikings group uh and then in the
last movie
then they they they they have this weird
situation where the dragon of hiccups
is trying to is having like a weird
romantic relationship with like the
his mother's dragon it's weird weird
weird
and like his and then his father dies
and so and then his dragon and her
dragon are having this like weird kind
of romantic thing it's just
very odd it's very i when i was watching
like what are they doing
why are they doing this it's very
disturbing
anyways i hope i'm the only person who
saw that
oh no now now i've infected all of you
with that perception
but it's like it was just very odd uh
all right
all right okay so we are done with
the the symbolic world
so let's move on to patreon
all right here we go
all right so tanner mathis uh now it's
on patreon ask
in your recent videos about marx have
made me think about how glasses are a
mark
they give their users the ability to see
properly but they also
are also a signal of a deficiency which
requires
technology to be corrected why do
sunglasses not have a similar impact on
our perception of someone
is it because they only solve a problem
which everyone
has so they are not really a mark of
deficiency
or does it have something to do with
their ability to obscure the eyes yes
there you go i was like i hope
he gets there because you're that's what
it is that's what sunglasses are
and that's the double aspect of the veil
right the double aspect of uh
of the supplement like one of the
aspects of the supplement or one of the
aspects of the veil
is to protect the to protect with that
which is
behind it so that's why you hide
something that's why you wear clothing
so you protect so you wear clothing to
protect
to protect yourselves from the cold but
you also wear clothing to protect
yourself from the stairs of others
right you want to you want to keep
decency inside and so
the sunglasses they act as a way to
shield your eyes from the sun
but then they have that's the original
purpose of the sunglasses
but then there's a secondary purpose of
sunglasses
was it was it which are to hide your
eyes from other people
and you can see it like rock stars use
sunglasses that way you know
you saw that you see those interviews in
the in the 80s or 90s with rockstars
that are wearing sunglasses and you
don't know where they're looking you
don't know what's going on
you you your face with like a mask uh
and so that is the the uh the other
aspect of sunglasses which is more kind
of a social
social version of what the social the
sunglasses do
all right so i'm new to this so jason
jason
jason schweitzer i'm new to this and i'm
not sure if this is where i submit
questions yes it is so the best of my
knowledge the name benjamin means son of
my right hand
but every time someone is described as
left-handed in scripture it states that
they are from the tribe of benjamin
what on earth is going on here maybe
it's obvious and i'm just not
getting it also thank you so much for
everything you are doing god bless you
and your family and so
man if you only knew
uh if you only knew how much i've
thought about this
[Music]
and it i in that in that thing in that
in that question there's the whole
there's like a whole uh relationship
between the like
the crossing over from the left hand to
the right hand this
this this thing that i've talked to you
about and makes
drives me crazy the relationship between
the left the left
when applied to myself right
the left when i am acting on the left
hand and then the left
when i am acting on others and so it has
to do with that it has to do with this
flip
which happens between the left and the
right hand and so i'm afraid that
one day so i'm telling you i'm promising
you guys one day i will make
a crystal clear video about this that
clearer than anything you've ever heard
on the symbolism of the left and the
right hand it's almost there but it's
not quite there
uh and then hopefully in that video i
will find a
i will find a final solution i think
that materials probably figured this one
out more than i have
should ask him
so anne herrera says i've noticed that
you threw a lot of shade towards
charismatics
i find this amusing and so i'm asking
this question in the same sphere besides
the obvious perversions and pitfalls of
that any expression of christianity can
fall into what exactly do you disagree
or dislike in the charismatic tradition
i've read your bro's book and it seems
to me that charismatics especially in
worship
have this beautiful meeting of time and
space in which they wholly submit
themselves to god hierarchy order and
fully open themselves up
the potential of the spirit to move in
unexpected ways
um and then
she says that i should ask people to
vote for the uh the questions that's
probably something that will happen at
some point because
right now there are too many questions
and so i struggle to get through them
and so first of all i want to apologize
when i throw shade
at different branches of christianity
it's not the proper way to do it and i
and i've been several people close to me
have told me that i have to i
that i should avoid doing that and i
will and i will try to do that just
because
i don't think it's the proper way to
approach things there are some things
that i disagree with
in terms of protestants but there is no
need
to do it that way especially when we're
in this kind of moment of uh
of breakdown we need to encourage each
other as much as possible but having
said that
i will nonetheless answer your question
my impression of charismatics is
that they are something
like that they the issue that they have
is something like
a kind of wildness of spirit like a
there's a kind of um
there's actually is a a
a lack of stability let's say so that's
why charismatic groups tend to split all
the time
uh you know because there is a sense in
which
there because there is a a there's an
attachment to this kind of direct
connection to the spirit and there isn't
a grounding
a proper grounding in in the kind of
stabilizing
uh forms of hierarchy and of tradition
then there's a tendency to
to kind of uh to lose yourself in the
spirit right to
to kind of
to only keep this is so so imagine like
in pentecost there is an element of
pentecost which is that everybody
perceives them as drunk and so there's a
drunkenness that is real
let's say in in in in the the spirit but
it's mitigated by other aspects
of the church you know by the fact that
saint peter rises up and kind of acts as
the leader of the apostle by
by all of these all of these different
things that that
that are kind of holding it together um
that is what i feel is the danger of the
charismatic uh tradition
and and so it goes in all these
directions and and all these gifts and
all of these miracles and all of this
stuff
and uh and it tends to fragment so but
you know i think
i've met many a charismatic person that
is
that is extremely
that are extremely sincere and extremely
dedicated
and so and so and i've learned quite a
bit from some of them so i want to make
sure that that's out there as well
but i do disagree with their theology
and their ecclesiology as well
so all right hopefully that's good
enough so bjorn olsen says hello
jonathan
i hope you are doing well this is more
of a request and a question
i would really like to see your inter
symbolic interpretation of frankenstein
especi specifically the original novel
by mary shelley
now there's your ai for you yeah the
novel also has some quite interesting
themes
of turning death against death perhaps
the future halloween video
and just to bring an actual question
what kind of music do you like uh
and so yeah i agree
i think i think mary shelley's
frankenstein is a prophetic book
um and i think it manifests a lot of the
issues of
of the arrogance of science the
arrogance of man you know the arrogance
of artificiality you know if you think
of
things like frankenstein and the story
of the golem
and the the appearance of robots on the
horizon let's say
around this a similar time in terms of a
concept
all of that is uh is is is very
important
to understand but uh yeah i could
definitely do that
maybe that's a good idea to do it on
halloween you know i have read it so
and what kind of music do i like i don't
listen to music anymore
i used to listen to music you know i
actually really did used to like kanye
west a lot
and i listened to and i kind of grew up
on uh
i been a guy of the 90s you know i grew
up on that kind of music
just kind of uh i was a skater so i
liked punk music
and i liked uh kind of alternative music
you know
was it like like was it the first
concert i went to
the pixies in the in the in the early
90s or late
late 80s early 90s um so it gives you an
idea of what i like when i was a
teenager but uh but i don't listen to
music these days
actually the only music i listen to now
is bach i just especially when i need to
do something in which i'm focused i like
listen to bach
and then uh then it helps me get super
focused
um so hi john so ender's ralph's dad
says hi jonathan can you tell me about
the most extreme memory that you have
from your time in africa maybe it
involves the basket behind you
yeah was this a symbolism happens kind
of moment yes it was
and so indeed i think i mentioned this
in a video before but for those who
haven't heard that basket that you see
behind me right here um this is a
rwandan
basket and uh
i uh we actually my wife and actually
bought it in
burundi when we were in the great lakes
area of africa at some point
and when we returned to congo we
came to uh to the east of congo
and uh we were supposed to be there just
for one day and then take a plane back
to kinshasa
and uh and the war started while we were
while we were staying there and we got
stuck in a swedish guest house
we actually were in the newspaper in
like the national swedish newspaper
there was a picture of us
caught in that uh between two walls as
they were bombing and shelling the city
and so uh i just have the memory because
at some point we tried to get the un to
come get us
um and so luckily the head of the u.n in
congo was the swedish guy
and so the people from the swedish guest
house had like an inn with him
so they called him but they could never
come and get us because every time
they would talk it would start shooting
again and there would be shelling and
explosions
um and it was weird like we the
people were trying to kind of relax as
the the whole
place was was being bombed and so they
watched
the meet the parents they would like
play the movie
and then the bombing would become so
loud that they would have to stop
the that they would have to stop the
movie while
while we were just sitting there sorry
i'm laughing you know i laugh in the
worst possible moments
it's just i'm not supposed to laugh here
anyways so finally they get
they get in contact with the uh the head
of the un
and um and so they decided they're going
to come get us
at the at the guest house but we need to
get our stuff in our room we were like
in a common building and we needed to go
get our stuff in a room
and that basket was in our room
and so i left the main building where
you were
and there was a shooter that was on the
corner of the wall
of our of where we were staying and uh
and so there were bullets that were
whizzing through the trees
and i actually at some point like these
bullets were whizzing over my head and i
had to
i had to kind of like duck on the ground
and i just remembered feeling this like
rush my goodness it was like it was the
most insane rush that i've ever felt
um and so i went into the room and got
this basket and uh
we were we were evacuated to the un
compound
and there at the um compound everybody
was drunk
everybody was completely drunk and it
was just
absolutely insane anyway so that's the
most intense
memory i have from congo it goes on and
it involves
being threatened with weapons that's you
know uh being caught in our
in our in our house because everything
broke down after that and there were
riots in the street it was an intense
very very intense time
but if you were interested it's very
strange because where we were staying in
the un compound
uh there was a punk band that uh
they're called sum 41 and they were in
the compound with us
i didn't know about them at the time i
learned about them later
but they were in the they were in the
compound where we were and they actually
filmed everything
and so you can find it online it's a
there's a video called rockton congo
uh which documents this whole event and
so i only watch it like
10 years later or maybe less maybe like
eight or nine years later i watched this
video and i'm watching
this thing that i went through in this
like this
this video by a punk band anyways it was
it was a wild
it was a while time so that was my most
intense but there are many many
that are at a similar level of intensity
yeah so that's why i keep that basket
there
to remind me of death
all right okay um
let's see
let me just check something
all right so i needed to look it up
because someone says can you comment on
psalm 133 it's only three verses
and so it says problems 133 let me read
it how good and pleasant it is when
god's people live together in unity
it is like precious oil poured on the
head
running down the beard running down on
aaron's beard down on the collar
of his robe it is as if the dew of
hermann were falling on mount zion
from there the lord bestows his blessing
even life forevermore
so you can see it if you want to if you
okay so let me say it as a mystery if
you would like and then because it's
only three verses you can figure it out
if you want to understand the
relationship the relationship between
emanation and emergence if you want to
understand the relationship between
top down and bottom up there
is your image and we talked about it
before so oil light
this light coming down from above and
running down
the head and the beard of the priest you
know and then
going down all the way down you can
imagine it goes down all the way to the
fringe of his robe let's say
um i wonder if i'm sure that when it
says down the collar of his robe i'm
wondering if it's
going down to the fringe of his robe
let's say and so you have this this
light coming down and then it says the
do on mount hermon
the do of herman were falling on mount
zion and so now you have this dew
on the ground right
on the mountain so you have the light
coming from above you have the dew on
the mountain which is something like
you know the say this it's like the
bubbling up of the earth or of
possibilities like this little
water on the ground that is waiting you
know
uh it's like the feminine down there and
the the dew on the mountain is
is the feminine let's say um and so
and then it says you know from there for
there the lord bestows his blessing and
life forevermore and it's like that's
how life works it has from above and
from below
meeting together meeting of heaven and
earth that's
what's going on there
uh why lauren says what do you think of
think the massive popularity of
asmr says about modern society
hey whatever just another freak just
another i mean just another thing that
is
in an idiosyncrasy which is uh
which could be another idiosyncrasy or
all the all the weird um stuff that get
people excited
um
so dan diego de la vega says hi jonathan
you're a matter of explaining the
symbolism within christianity
was one of the significant missing
pieces that brought me back to the face
so thank you well it's my pleasure
in the movie beowulf beowulf sneers at
the christian faith saying it has ended
the age
of heroes and left them with only
weeping martyrs
movie ends with beowulf sacrificing
himself for his loved ones from
the dragon he created through his own
sin then he dies on the beach
with tears in his eyes hoping you've
seen the movie would
you have any thoughts on that yes i have
many thoughts on that and thought i have
on that
is that here again
am i going to go on a rant on neil
gaiman again here is neil gaiman
not understanding christianity but being
haunted by christianity
because it's a christian story which is
criticizing curtis christianity
the version that he created is such a
christian story
where he where he has to like where he
where
he sins and then his sin comes to haunt
him
and then he has to make atonement for
his sin it's like
and then he sacrifices himself as the
final atonement
for his own sin
it's a good christian story for a story
that goes that is all about
bashing christianity oh
man
all right so deucenbabik says hi
jonathan i feel like i'm in a weird mood
i'm going to say something really weird
is what i'm afraid of here
why in hydrographical text it is often
said that the pagans worship
stone and wood when we know they have
different stories about for example
zeus as a real living entity doing stuff
didn't they think of idols or statues of
gods
as representations of real gods thank
you for your work greetings from serbia
yeah that is it's
it's an interesting point you make and i
think your point is
the best way to understand this and and
biblical scholars are going to
hate me for saying this but the best way
to understand it
is that you can understand it like
the hebrews were were encountering the
fringe
of the tradition right
they were kind of encountering
the the the these other traditions in
there
at their end where in fact they had kind
of devolved in something like our
materialism
but not exactly but something like it
where they were confusing the letter for
the spirit and they were even
even though their idols were already
suspicious because they were these wild
principalities
that they it was even lower than that
where they were just basically
you know worshiping the matter of it you
know and worshiping the matter
so if you think that's not possible it's
like what do you think that
the new atheists were like what do you
think all this all these
scientific materialists are doing
they're doing exactly that so it's not
that weird to think that that's what
they were encountering they're
encountering something like a
completely decadent uh tradition
um yeah so
so walrus king 14 hi jonathan nowadays
it seems that most people
either understand luck from a
materialist point of view where it's
seen simply as a numerical possibility
or from a sort of divination perspective
where luck is a force to be controlled
lady luck and the use
of things like charms special clothes
and personal rituals how do either of
these understandings compare to how the
people of the ancient
and medieval eras understood luck and
how do we reconcile the notion of luck
with our belief that everything happens
according to god's will
does luck have room to exist within the
christian mind
so lots have room to exist in the
christian mind
and so you can understand it as luck in
the sense that on the edge of reality
there's a place where order breaks down
and that things become idiosyncratic and
that they don't follow
logic and so the the
that's that's lots and so lots are
ambiguous they can be they can become
the place
of the highest insight you know and you
see that in scripture for example you
see
that the the ancient hebrews
had these stones that they used to uh to
discern the will of god that they would
probably cast and that they would be
able to read
um and you see it also in the election
of the new
apostle where they cast lots in order to
discern the will of god
so you can understand it as the as a
possibility of a place where there's
insight
but it also can devolve into the other
aspect of luck which is this
giving in to to uh
to to illogic to the illogical and
giving yourself into
the into uh the place where
where logic breaks down so gambling uh
you see in scripture it says that
the there's a there's a place where it
says that for example so the hebrews had
this ephod with the with the stones on
it and they would use that to cast but
there's a place for example in joshua
where it says that
that they became that they they kind of
uh
what's the word that they use but
something like they defiled themselves
with the ephod like that basically
this same word this ephod became became
a place for them to kind of
become like to kind of fall into chaos
and to
and to and to defilement so you can
understand it as these extremes you know
so you know the the idea of the will of
wheel of fortune
is a good is a good example of that that
was kept in the middle ages
where the sense where if you give
yourself over to fortune then
fortune is a mistress right fortune is a
wheel fortune is a
is a trickster and you know if you give
yourself just to the world of
that kind of world where you give
yourself the fortune then you will
you will find yourself above you find
yourself below like you you you know go
the wheel of fortune goes round and
round and you don't know
uh you don't know where where where it's
going to
where it's going to take you so um
so yeah so something like so i think the
word best word to use is chance
you know the use of chance
all right so vianney do tell noir says
hello jonathan why the altars have four
horns
they're linked to the patricic tradition
that the burning bush had
thorns what about abraham finding a ram
with his horn stuck in a bush
on mount moriah may god bless you your
family and your work so
the four horns have to do with just four
in general it has to do with four
extensions and so it has to do with a
square
it has to do with the box has to do with
the idea of
four corners which create uh stability
and so
imagine the four horns on the four
corners of the altar
something like the four the four glories
not exactly but the idea of these four
manifestations
right and so you have four directions
those are four horns as well
you have you know this it's the creation
of stability
you know that you're four now for a horn
is a point it's a it's a it's a point
so it's like four points you need four
points
in order to create uh stability if you
just have two
then you have duality if you have three
you have this kind of dynamic
relationship
if you have four points then you have a
kind of stable
a stable thing on which the world can
can work and so so think of it more like
think of it something like the four
directions if if that can help you to
understand it that way so it's like
it's an extension of the world and it's
in its different directions
so the altar is like a little microcosm
which has four directions and you cover
them with blood
in order to cover the world with blood
or cover the
extension of your of your manifestation
with blood extension of the country
extension of the people that are coming
to sacrifice you
cover them you cover the corn to the
altar and it
it's like it's like a ritual act which
represents the covering of
of space itself right so it's just space
itself is a good way to maybe understand
it
um a square yeah
that's the best i can do with that
how many are left man it's like 9 20.
so artem carnock asked hi jonathan
thanks a lot for your work
uh some orthodox churches including the
church in ukraine that i belong to you
church levonic language and liturgical
and everyday
prank practice what is symbolic meaning
of using a language that people have a
hard time understanding
does this function like a veil that
protects the altar from being fully
exposed to the people
i also thought that using it can
function like a remedy for the fallen
human nature
that is attracted to something foreign
and marginal
um so so this is
i think i think it's it's more has more
to do with unity
and so the idea is that you use a
language which binds more people
together
so you can imagine you use greek and so
greek
binds the entire at the beginning of
of christianity greek is something in
which
all the different peoples of the
mediterranean had access to
so it was actually a way to create a
kind of universe a small
you universal language that people can
that can function under so now imagine
now you have these greeks and then you
have these
russians these slavic people and they
have nothing to do with you like they
have no they don't understand your
your thing like they're not greeks they
have nose there they're not connected to
the world
so now you want to evangelize them so
what do you do you you're like okay so
if i evangelize them if i try to bring
them the message of christ am i going to
do it in
every single one of their like dialects
am i going to like am i going to
or rather is christianity actually going
to become
a way to bind larger groups of people
together
and so the the missionaries go to the
slavic lands they actually
give the slavic people their an alphabet
and in giving them an alphabet they they
modified
the language they had to or they had to
at least condense it
symbolize it right they had to bring it
together into something which could be
recognized by everybody but also not be
exactly the way everybody speaks because
everybody speaks different everybody has
their little dialects and little
accents or little ways of doing things
so you have to find a way to join all
these people together in a common
language and so that's why it looks that
way the same thing with latin
the same thing with like amharic in
ethiopia the same thing with any
liturgical language it's a way to
bind more people together uh but it does
have a negative
there's a negative aspect to that which
like you said which is that if
the languages that it's supposed to bind
together
move out too far then at some point it
loses its capacity to bind
them together you know and so
so then you have to find some kind of
compromise
and so you'll see it in parishes like
sometimes you'll say okay well we'll do
the liturgy
in slavonic but we'll do the gospel in
russian or ukrainian or in the local
language
you know in order to also condescend
to to the local place where i am we'll
do the homily and
in a local language um but you have to
understand that ukrainian russian all
the slavic language
they all have commonality in
in slavonic right just like all the
romance language have
commonality in latin and so that's why
even today the catholic church to its
strength
keeps latin as its official language
even though they translated all the
liturgies
they still use latin in terms of all
their if you write a
uh like a theological treaties for the
church if you write a
like an encyclical or whatever it has to
be written in latin because
it's the it is nonetheless the language
in which all of
western christianity kind of finds its
unity um so that's how you kind of have
to understand it
so it's so so the idea of like of
translating and moving towards
multiplicity and unity
it's a tricky thing and you really have
to understand it it's tricky so let's
say
this like you so you translate the
liturgy
into english so which english are you
going to translate it into
right because if you go if you go to
queens
in uh in new york or if you
like go to arizona if you
depending on where you go in the u.s and
depending on which level of education
you're dealing with
the english is not going to be the same
and so you have to find a way to
translate it into
english in a way that binds them binds
people together
that is not too high it's not too low
that is somewhere in the middle
so even when they translate it into
local languages the problem of
slavonic that you pose becomes the same
problem
it becomes the same problem it's just
not as immediate because people
because something like slovanna gets so
it's kind of far
behind and languages have changed so
much that people struggle to see
to recognize the the the place of unity
let's say
so it's tricky
so chase and lindsay hey jonathan is
materialism just a giant century
spanning anti-magic spell
or network of anti-magic spells yeah
that's a good way to understand it
the good magic and the bad magic
but it's a spell with a countdown it
doesn't last and then when it runs out
then it leaves then it for some reason
all the dark magic comes in first
so you know it's not great
so duration says hi jonathan is jesus
sweating a blood a mini version of the
blood and water coming out of his side
of the cross
also is there a relation to giving birth
and opening blood and water
so for sure when when christ is pierced
on the cross there's a relationship with
giving birth you see that in the church
fathers all the time
you know you hear it in the hymns during
the during uh the holy week
and so yes i never thought about that in
terms of but i think
you're on to something i think you're
definitely onto something the idea of
sweating blood
as a mini version of that good catch
yeah i think you i think you're on to
something
johnny wrath jonathan what's the
symbolism of the five-second rule if you
drop a bit of food and it's perfectly
fine to eat
it has only been on the floor for five
seconds i don't know
and then two how do you feel uh being
the intersection between
the idw and the afcu i don't know what
the afc
is what's the afcu and what the afc
is does somebody know what that is in
the court in the in the chat
um all right i have no idea and what's
the symbol of the five second rule i
mean it
i think it's it's the symbolism of
understanding that the earth is the
place of death
and that if something is on the ground
for too long then it's dead you can't
eat it
and then you can't if you can't you
can't uh
consume it anymore you know it's a funny
funny way of thinking because we eat
stuff from the ground
all the time but you know i think that's
what it is
it has to do with recognizing that the
earth is a place of death
someone samuel ramilera says afc
american first credit union
yeah i think it's probably not that i'm
i think it's probably not that
all right okay so uh awana says i
jonathan
thank you for all you do heard jesus
sanctified the life stages of people's
lives
just by living them wondering about old
age though
any insight um
i mean he saves adam so you know
it's good enough in terms of in terms of
uh
sanctifying uh and sanctifying old age
that's the best way i would see that
so john nathan hart said jonathan sorry
if you addressed this already recent set
of videos on satanic imagery as i've not
gotten around to watching them
all yet but what is the meaning of saint
peter being crucified upside down my
instinct
is that it's signifying the descent of
god to earth through his church
mirroring humanity's ascent
to god through christ
there's this there's a lot of mystery
dude there's mystery in that
and there's mystery in st peter
there's some mysterious stuff in that
i think i don't want to go into that now
i
i promise you that i one day make a
video on that
uh and it has to do has
well i could say it simply it has to do
with the double symbolism
of peter it has to do with the fact that
peter is both
the stone on which christ builds his
church
and the satan
at the same time you can't just have you
can't just
look for one in peter if you look just
for one you're missing something
and so you can understand that the cross
is upside down in the sense that it's a
it's a it's a reflection
of christ it's in a pool of water it
becomes also like a
like a foundation like a
pillar planted in the earth let's say
but like
say peter's head is planted in the earth
let's say
and it becomes a foundation stone and
then christ's
head is above and so that means that he
is both the
pillar
yeah that's that's that's the mystery of
peter
yeah and it seems to be a cosmic mystery
of some kind
that will yeah anyways all right let's
keep going here evie
how should we think about organ donation
should chris should participate in this
um i think it's okay i don't
it doesn't bother me it's because it's
like the body is
you know yes you you manifest yourself
in your body but you're getting body
from other things all the time it's not
like you
your body is just something that you
don't get from the outside and so
i think it's okay
so andy crawford says it was harry
potter that fully awakened me to the
symbolic world
or what i usually call a sacramental
worldview forgive me if i have already
if you have already talked about this
somewhere but in general
what do you think of the way rowling
uses symbolism in the harry potter story
maybe that would maybe what you think is
a symbolic highlight
in the story and or symbolic myths my
personal favorite is the demonic
inversion of circle imagery in
voldemort's cave in book says i have not
read the books by the way
so it's like i'm not like i have this
big uh
it's not like i have this big
understanding of of
i just watched the movies once i wasn't
super impressed by
harry potter i'm sorry i just i don't
know why i don't necessarily have a
reason
um
there's something about it which was so
technical it's
i really hate the idea that
something like magic is just treated
simply like a technical thing like a
like a kind of uh just like a chemical
formula that you
that you get right and then because you
get this chemical formula right
then then all of a sudden it's like
you're a powerful wizard
there's something about that which i
really dislike
in terms of the use of magic in a in a
more story
in a kind of story telling and so
so yeah i think that's probably why i
didn't like harry potter i just didn't
really completely get attached to it
because i there's something about the
way that they treated
they treated that that i didn't enjoy
all right so stephen bishop says i've
often seen icons the martyrdom of saint
ignatius of antioch being eaten by two
lines one upright
on his right and one upside down on his
left is this formation
in this formation they almost make a
circle as though they were going to flip
is this an example of turning death into
glory yes
i don't i think it's mostly an example
of kind of the right hand and the left
hand and
and him being the center of these two
extremes let's say
it seems that's what it seems to me i
really also am very attracted to that
image i find it there's something about
it which is very
powerful and so you can imagine like two
snakes let's say you know like the
idea of the the caduceus with like the
two snakes like a left hand and a right
hand snake or the bishops
the bishops crozier with the two snakes
on the side
it seems like there's something to do
with that uh
but but the the proper understanding
that one snake is going up and when
snake is going down
uh which is probably a better
understanding of those two
those two tendencies let's say um
and so yeah it's definitely an image of
of of saying
nation becoming like the center and then
animality being around him
and you know he becomes almost like a
ladder or he becomes the
the an image of this place where where
where things connect together um and so
i think it has to do with that like the
two serpents all of that
so keenan wang asked an icon of
pentecost there's often a man in the
world
what is the significance of how he is
represented and where he exists in the
picture
so he is he's outside that's the most
important part is to understand that the
the dark space at the bottom of the icon
of pentecost which is black
is the door to the outside and so
the the the king king cosmos you know
is is the outside itself it's kind of
like
the the old cosmos
the old world let's say that's reached
its end
and so usually if you see him he's he's
holding uh
he's holding like a veil or like a cloth
and in the cloth there like there are 12
rolls
so those 12 rolls are something like
the 12 teachings or the 12 extensions
of the the 12 apostles or the 12 that
are there because it's not even the
apostles that are there it's like a
it's a kind of a more synthetic image of
the 12 let's say
that the idea of these 12 then extending
out into the world
and being received you know in 12
languages or 12 different
extensions of of christ manifesting
himself
and so that's the way to understand that
so it's like a
like an old dead man who is at the edge
of the world
and is in darkness and then receives
the the the the out
the expression of these 12 rays of light
you could say and so it fills the world
right it's all flesh
when it says in um in uh in the psalms
and in different places in the old
testament that the spirit will
cover all flesh and so that's what it it
seems to represent but not just all
flesh but all things
so it's like it's not just people it's
also all of creation which is
filled with the spirit of god um
yeah so drew mcmahon says any thoughts
on rasputin
i don't have any thoughts on residue
there seems to be different opinions
about him i've met
particularly orthodox people who see him
almost as a saint
and then other people see him as
basically the cause of all of
the the breakdown of russia so i don't
know i don't know enough about rescue
so g garcia says what's the symbolism of
body switching stories
it's mostly those those stories are
mostly about uh
they're mostly they're mostly about this
weird
this weird kind of duality that people
think exists between the body and the
soul
which is a which is a it's an illusion
illusion the idea that you're
that your body is just a is a shell
right the ghost in the shell idea that
it's just a shell and you're like that
you're like this kind of pure spirit
that's not how it works you know
identities have to be embodied
in body so you can't switch bodies it
doesn't mean anything like
who is you that is switching bodies
um so that's what i think i don't i
don't i i find i find them uh
i find that they're they're an image of
the kind of gnosticism that we engage in
and just in popular culture
so garrett witner says i was wondering
on the symbolism of nuclear power
specifically when the atom is split and
the radiation associated with that
i mean it it has to do it has to do with
the idea that
power is contained in matter you know in
a in an extreme potential way
and that you know you have to be careful
unleashing that because it
is it is there's a lot of power hidden
underneath the world let's say that
that's what is hidden underneath the
world is power it's potential but there
is a lot of it
and so you have to be careful when you
go down there
and try to break you know you try to
break these little
these little uh identities
so charlie longoria says what do you
think of john viveki telling jordan
peterson he thinks you are a more
radical christian than you realize
i don't know i don't know what i think
of that
i have to talk to him about it you know
jordan
jordan peters and john vivek and i are
going to record a video together
we we already have a date in september
we're going to do like a three
three-way discussion the three of us um
so hopefully that'll go okay i'm a
little nervous about that because
the discussion between john and jordan
was like it was kind of hyper it was
like this weird hyper
mode and jordan was being really
mischievous for some reason i don't
totally understand why
uh but uh i'm still looking forward to
it i think it's gonna be interesting
because i think
i think john has a lot to offer in terms
of
in terms of places where we can connect
you know
spiritual understanding with uh kind of
materialism
so i think that he's really helpful and
i think jordan gets him
um and so so yeah i think i think it'll
be interesting but i don't know i don't
know totally what he meant by that
because jordan kind of took him off
right he always takes him off he would
during the whole conversation he's
constantly like taking him off the path
uh of what he was saying and so i didn't
totally understand what he meant i could
ask him you could tell me
um so daniel demarco says
jonathan there are many lists of names
in the old testament including
chronicles ezra and nehemiah
they are often interspersed with short
descriptions like musicians
gatekeepers etcetera anecdotes what if
anything can i make of these lists of
names is it worth reading them
diligently or can they be skimmed or
skipped over
so lists of names are really important
they're super important
they're just difficult to attend to
usually they
like like genealogies are very important
lists of names are very important
because usually you can find
in the meaning of the names you can
actually find a kind of little story in
the list of the names and so
if you have the capacity to pay
attention to that i would say it's
definitely worth it
but it's it requires a lot of effort
all right so mark peter says hi jonathan
how can symbolic analysis be used to say
more about our experience of time
given our ability to for example watch
youtube video
or of a performer singing on tv in the
1970s and juxtaposed another video on a
screen of the same performer singing the
same song
on the same stage on tv 15 years later
i don't know what to tell you i'm not
sure with your example what you're
saying
um
yeah i'm not sure so i mean for sure
technology is messing up our
our technology is messing up our
understanding of time and of space
that's for sure
right because in the internet you are
you're standing in one space yet
you're basically everything is reduced
to time where all space seems available
to you
you know in time um but at the same time
like you said this
media is also somehow and sometimes
giving you a sense that it's kind of
collapsing time
at this at you know at the same time so
i don't know it's uh
it's definitely another example of
things breaking down
chandler turner says can you do a short
symbolic analysis of the anarchy a
i don't think i've ever thought about
that
interesting
i have to think about it all i can say
is i had to think about it
it's definitely a pentagram um
so there's that
so it definitely has something to do
with the pentagram but i'd have to i'd
have to think about
it more that's a very provocative
question because it still look because
it's still like an
a so it still seems to have like a kind
of hierarchy to it
and you think about it good question
micah mueller says maybe this is
something you have been hinting
at for a long time but i'm noticing many
parallels between peterson and saint
christopher
such as the similarity structurally
sorry between
peterson's asking why it's christopher
wanting to serve the most powerful king
how should we consider such
manifestations
i mean yeah if you watched the video i
did on
the metaphysics of pepe you'll notice
that i'm pointing at that all the time
so if you can watch that and you can get
a sense
of the relationship between the frog you
know taking the golden ball out of the
water
and say christopher crossing the golden
child across the river
and you know
that kind of stuff so kevin peterson
says
when we die why shouldn't we stay with
the saints why bother coming back to
earth and getting bodies again
if we can exist without them
i shouldn't laugh because obviously it's
a great really good question
it's like it's like one of those
questions which nobody dares to ask
uh and so this is this is why
it's so ambiguous like
okay what i'm gonna tell you don't take
what i'm telling you as like this is the
rule
but
okay so feel free to disagree with me
and feel
and don't call like like on priests to
come and get me because i'm saying
something which sounds weird but
i think the best way to understand that
is that the saints are already in the
eschaton
and that they are
something like they are already
answering us from their resurrected
bodies
that's the best way that i have to
understand that
um because
there is a there's a sense in which that
we're not we don't exist
without bodies and so there really is a
sense in which
th you can feel it every time you hear
descriptions of the afterlife where
there's an ambiguity there's like
we don't there's like a thing they talk
about the particular judgment the
universal judgment there's a way in
which they try to kind of fudge it
to to say you're in a waiting place like
whatever
who knows like it's not it's all kind of
i mean
and i don't want to criticize the way
that it's been described before
um but for me that's the best that's
really the best way to understand it
is that the kingdom of god is there
among you and the eschaton is already
available because it's not doesn't
participate in time in the same way
that linear time does and so it's
already there
and that the resurrection
is mysteriously already there
so there you go don't take that don't
take that to the bank though
all right so anjo terpstra does the song
have an angel
i've noticed there are multiple
songwriters who approach songs as if
they have a spirit
as if songs are patterns not inside but
outside the songwriter which whom they
try to connect are they from a symbolic
perspective connecting to the angel of
the song
or would this maybe be the logos of the
song or this or is this
basically the same so i think
i think it's probably not the song that
has an angel but it's
it's say patterns certain patterns have
angels and so
to the extent that a song will
participate in a certain pattern then
yes it will be subject to
to a principality um but it's not
necessarily just like
you don't necessarily have to understand
it that each song has an angel
and it's like think about it like the
muses for example like the muses
they didn't you didn't have to have a
muse for every
for every for every single artwork that
was produced but rather they had
separated the muses
among the different arts as kind of
these inspiration principalities for
the different arts and so i think it's
probably better to understand it some
something like that
so david goliath and el hanan i've been
raised in a christian home all my life
and have been orthodox for a decade two
days ago while listening to brett
weinstein i heard him speak of el hanan
never in my life if i heard this view
what do you know and what can you share
about this topic
um and so i don't know like i don't know
what he said i did have to hear what he
said about el hanan
um in the idea that el hanan killed
goliath and so
there there are plenty of ways to deal
with that
one is to understand that goliath is a
title and not
a not uh not a name like a name in the
in the proper sense and so there are
different there are several goliaths
and david slew and goliath and
el hanan slew of goliath and there were
giants
in the canaanites and in the philistines
and all of them so
that to me like in terms of in terms of
just narrative that's not a big deal
uh but i don't know enough about el
hanan
and his own slaying of goliath and what
that like what that could mean because
usually we
we attend to david because there's a
longer story which describes his killing
of uh of goliath
so yeah but if it bothers you in terms
of narrative like in terms of
it being a contradiction or whatever
it's i don't i don't see why it would
it's not a big deal
so no norm golden in your conversation
with ray of kelly you talk about your
beliefs being grounded fundamentally and
intuition of the pattern
do you think that our beliefs regardless
of whether we try to ground them bottom
up or top down in the end
always come from above from a
fundamentally unidentifiable mystery or
intuition
that rests upon a felt but unprovable
axiom
perhaps the limit of the bottom-up crowd
to recognize this or scale beyond the
individual to cities nations and beyond
is due to their inability or
unwillingness to admit mystery
there are things that exist that are
beyond our fundamental ability to
understand well
yeah i mean i think for sure what you're
saying is
is is right um
all right so don palermo my question is
regarding sorry
the relevant relevancy of christ
imperative do not resist evil
in relationship to deeply disturbing and
seemingly unsurmountable drive
for transhumanist goals to merge with
body with machine
what does it mean to be a temple as an
image bearing human in this context and
decides
the mark where else might it be a line
for us to pay attention to
so i mean it's very simple there's a
difference between don't
the difference between not resisting
evil
and not collaborating with evil those
are not the same thing
and that's it like that's the difference
right the the idea that ultimately the
highest
the highest uh the highest form
the highest form let's say of of
transcendence would be something
like that you're not defined by the
outside at all
and so you don't have to resist evil so
it's like if someone slaps you
it doesn't define you you don't you're
fine you continue on your life
and so you're not defined by the outside
in any way
right that's the highest aspect um
but that doesn't mean that if that if uh
i don't know if someone comes and says
here come with me and let's rob this
person that you're gonna say yes
you're not going to say yes so you
cannot resist evil and you don't have to
give in to this
to the transhumanist goal to merge body
with machine
it's not a very complicated it's not i
mean it's complicated
in the practical because we're
surrounded by this stuff and and we fear
the pressure on all sides but
at least morally it's not it's not to me
it's not a complicated question
all right so matthew mull brandon asks
what is the margin
geographically in modern cities the
suburbs in north america are viewed
as white and or normal and predictable
but would seem to be the edge of the
city
is there something radical inside the
suburbs we don't see or is it simply
economic expression outside of the
traditional urban framework of the past
so there so the thing is that so this is
the thing is that there are different
aspects of the margin
uh and the margin the margin
uh is not always negative like the
margin is also positive so you can
understand the margin
this is this is going to be tough for
people to understand so there's an
aspect of the margin which is
conservative
it's like an ark it preserves it keeps
it's like
it's like the ark of the covenant it's
like a box that keeps things it's like
the
earth that you can dig and you can hide
things under so the earth is both a
place
of decomposition and the earth is also a
place where you find treasures
and so it's a place that preserves
just like it also destroys it's hard
it's hard to kind of understand that but
that those are the two aspects of the
margin and so
there's an aspect of the margin let's
say you take lord of the rings there's
an aspect of the margin
which are the orcs and gollum and mordor
there's an aspect of the margin which is
the shire the shire is bag
end that's what this you know it's like
bag end is the is the bottom it's it's
the bottom of the world
the shire is the bottom of the world the
folk are the bottom of the world
the the the common the commoners
right they are they're also the
basket they're also the the place where
things are held together they're also
the conservative element of society will
also be found
in the margin and so when the
when the when the priest and the king
go crazy the folk continue to do their
thing
and they're very difficult to change
like regular people are difficult to
change and that's good
it's great you know and so
that's that's how you have to understand
that so you're right
not this so like the suburbs but let's
say the outside of the city is more
conservative
it's more traditional it's more uh
working class it's more you know it has
you know and especially if you go
towards the flyover zones in
in the us it really even takes up that
aesthetic let's say
if you look at the the election in 2020
you can see
this idea of like the kind of democratic
uh
elite uh cities and then then the kind
of republican
countryside let's say and so that's it
that's the that's the shire
right that's the that's that aspect of
the margin
so all right so we have a few questions
on subscribe star
look at me i'm getting better though i
used to be able to like go an hour and a
half
and i could go two hours and now i feel
like i'm pretty good i could keep going
here
um so i'm gonna keep going as long as i
can
all right
so mary pope osborne says is there a
modern reading source other than the
bible that expounds
on the patterns of christianity that you
referred to
sometimes i can't see the forest for the
trees
and so
i mean there are plenty i mean my two my
brother's book is a great place to start
if you want
if you want to start here i'm plugging
his book again but you know i i think
it's worth it it's
it's a really good book on symbolism
it's called the language of creation
you can check that out it's definitely
worth it um
but there are people right now that are
that even like
in the orthodox tradition you'll find
just
in in terms of homilies you'll see go to
a church you'll you'll hear people talk
about it
the different use of uh of um
typology in christianity is popular all
over the place i don't know
like how to point you to a specific
thing but even in terms of
modern scholarship right now like you
can go to the bible project they're
protestant group but they're doing great
in terms of understanding bible
symbolism
you've got you've got
people like um what's the name of the
the theophilus institute with uh with
james jordan
um and all of these people you know
you've got
you've got people all all around i think
there there are places to look if you
want to look for uh
kind of narrative patterns in in
scripture you know
um yeah i don't know
but it's best to read the church fathers
read saint gregor vanessa and read uh
saint basel and read
saint maxwell the confessor you can read
text on the church fathers as well
in which they try to kind of help you
see
that you know there's a great
introduction on um
on saint max with the confessor by
andrew lauth which is worth it
um yeah
so xrd says hi jonathan are you familiar
with neon genesis evangelion
i think the internet would break if you
analyzed
it's symbolism you're not the first
person to tell me this so i don't know i
mean maybe one day
i don't watch a lot of stuff anymore
maybe one day
so big lasagna asked hello jonathan i
was thinking about what myths can bring
us
out of the situation we are nowadays in
i thought about the myth of the devil's
bridge
gives us a possible solution to the
question of technology do you know the
myth no i don't know the myth
and so i don't know how to answer that
and since we're coming to the end of the
questions i don't think i'm going to
look it up right now maybe i'll look it
up later and see what it is
so adrian malion says hi jonathan i have
a i've got a strong intuition that the
next step in your threat of
understanding
the identification of roaring with troy
is the story of dino
yes and aeneas they are associated with
roman carthage
and an internal conflict between the
city on the hill and the city on the
water
how do you interpret this um
i mean i don't know if there's a
relationship between
aeneas and dido and rome and troy um
i'd have to think about it like in terms
of i never thought about their
relationship as being related to
uh to me dido was like the strange woman
that's what she is that's what she
that's to me that's what she represents
she represents the strange principality
which
is very attractive and is honorable and
has
value but if you attach yourself to it
then you're going to get lost
you're not going to be able to continue
your line
you know and so that's what i see in
dido mostly
so all right so yeah so we are done with
the done with the
questions in the so
i'm going to go to the super chats here
we go so it's 10 o'clock
let's see how many there are
um
all right so let's see
all right so the golden thread asks
you've answered so many questions
about the nature of divine beings
principalities power logie
etc and their eternity versus our time i
still struggle
what are your sources on this what do i
read start with plato
i'm willing um i i think that if you're
if you're somehow somewhat of a
christian you might as well you might as
well go with say maximus and
you know like i just mentioned the book
by andrew lauth which is uh just called
samax with the confessor i think
that's a good place to start a nice
cosmic uh
a nice kind of cosmic vision of of saint
maximus's um
theology
um okay uh that was for 20 usd and so
the abc 1 2 3 4 5 six three nine nine
sim gives me a hundred dollars it just
says sarm's gang i don't know what that
is
thank you that's very nice so meebla
from 4.99 says i read matthew's book and
it got me thinking
is it legitimate to interpret the cross
of christ as a manifestation of the
spatial axis
and so yes it is but it's more than that
because it both has a horizontal
and a vertical and so it's both the axis
and the kind of the extension
right so it's the the cross is the axis
it's also the center it's also the
extensions
to the edge of the of a world let's say
and so and it also because christ is on
the cross and it's also
the serpent or the spiral around
the axis at the same time the cross is
just everything i don't know what to
tell you
sorry it's like i keep saying things
like that but it's true
it's just true um so
process raw wills for five dollars
says can you give your thoughts on the
euthyphro dilemma
i don't know what that is
so it is the dilemma in which socrates
asks asked euthyphro is the pious loved
by the gods because it is pious or is
the
or is it pious because it is love by the
gods
so i wish i could tell you that there is
an
answer to that but the answer is in
psalm 133
is that it's happening at the same time
it's top down and bottom up
at the same time that's how reality
works
so kimberly bolger for thirty dollars
cad
says what does the resurrection of
christ symbolize
does this relate to what christians
believe about going to heaven you're
amazing thanks
so kimberly
i cannot answer your question because
i don't know i'm not sure the
resurrection of christ doesn't symbolize
it symbolizes it's everything i don't
know what to tell you it's
how death becomes life it's how
something dies and lives again
it's it's the cycle of everything it's a
cycle of of the world coming to each
other it's the end of the beginning it's
the eighth day it's the seventh day it's
the you know it's the
the first day and the eighth day so with
the it's the
it's the very end in the very beginning
there's so much to say i couldn't sadly
i couldn't sadly tell you all that the
resurrection means you'd have to watch
all of my videos
to to get a sense of what i think the
resurrection means
so but thank you for saying i'm amazing
that's that's very kind of you so
kirsting queering for 999 says today's
my birthday so i thought i'd treat
myself with the question
what are your thoughts on intellectual
property owning ideas
can you own something without a body
thank you
i understand the practical reason for
intellectual property but i definitely
think that it's a
it's a problem like you said it's a it's
definitely a serious problem in terms of
kind of ontology you know the idea that
you can
own so what is it you own you do only
the pattern or do you own the
idiosyncrasies like
especially in terms of in terms of art
especially it's the hardest for me
it's just hard to to to get it i can
understand why you could own
some scientific uh application or
something like that um
so yeah so squillium for ten dollars usd
what is the orthodox
view of what christ accomplished to his
passion
in other words what is the good news of
the orthodox church
man you guys how can you ask these
questions
i i i i how can you ask me
what christ accomplished to his fashion
at like 10 o'clock at night after two
hours of speaking
um i would say i read the bible i don't
i
i would say yeah i don't know it's it's
too these questions are too encompassing
they're too big
to be answered quickly
so what did christ accomplish to his
passion he
he went into death and then abolished
death
there you go that's the best answer i
can give you
so jail for six australian what's the
symbolism of desalination
making seawater pot uh potable um
how do you pronounce that word in french
say patab potable
if you use the term bitter waters
and i'll be a happy man yes that's what
it's definitely related to that it's
definitely related to
the idea of changing bitter waters into
uh clean water and so it's the uh you
know the the the symbol of the cross
kind of come the tree being put into the
water
in order to in order to uh
change the bitter waters into sweet
waters so it definitely has something to
do with that
um but i i'd have to think about what it
would mean to do that artificially
because i mean this idea of making
seawater drinkable
is something which happens all the time
you know that's what the sun does the
sun
makes seawater drinkable again
all right so andrew davis for 10 years
do you see a parallel between the tower
of babel and modern-day globalism
it appears satan is once again trying to
gather the world to unite in a new
system
against god that's i mean it seems like
i mean they don't
it's hard not to see that there's a
poster i i've shared it once on social
media there's a poster
of the european union when they were
trying to put together the european
union they they had the gall to use an
image of the tower of babel
in one of their advertisements abrugal's
tower of babel even the one that's
unfinished
kind of showing that they're gonna
finish the tower of babel
is such pride it's insane
so it's it's simple the world exists
through fractal hierarchies
so in order for the world to hold
together the the pattern of the world
has to repeat itself
at all the different levels of reality
and so
the the the world exists through a
hierarchy of associations
right so you you you find your identity
and yourself in your family
in your friends in your soccer team
and your clubs in your interest groups
in your in your city in your nation and
your all of this is all
manifesting the pattern the same pattern
at all the different levels of reality
and it's acting like uh like a
like a like a set of roots
that is holding all everything together
so that that are
fractally structurally at every level of
identity manifesting itself now the
problem with something like the tower
babel or
the idea of globalism is to want to
break down
these intermediary units and just unite
everybody under one thing and that
doesn't work
it's going to do the opposite things are
going to start to fragment
they're going to start to break down
because
because the the the totalizing
identity is going to present itself as
being in competition
with these secondary identities and
that's not how it's supposed to be
it's supposed to layer itself up right
your family
is not in competition with the city it
shouldn't be
these are just different levels of
identity and so this is the problem with
this with the tower of babel it's a
problem
with globalism too is that they just
want us all to be united under one thing
i'm not sure what it is
is it is it like pride is it
just environment is it is it i don't
know it's hard to
totally understand what it is they want
us to unite under but they want to
replace
these these um secondary hierarchies
with just one thing
that now fills up the world so for
example if you look at this
the kind of woke uh infiltration of
organizations you can see that that's
what they're trying to do they're trying
to replace every goal of every
organization that they infiltrate
with the woke ideology and they want to
make that
the purpose of everything so the purpose
of a soccer team isn't to win the soccer
team
a soccer championship anymore it's to be
uh diverse right and to be
intersectional
so the purpose of uh the the the post
the
the the purpose of the u.s mail or the
canadian canadian post isn't to deliver
mail anymore
it's to be diverse it's to be
intersectional and it's that becomes
true in
every organization
but it doesn't work it just doesn't work
because it's breaking down the world
it's as it's trying to unite it under
one thing it's
actually destroying the the real
hierarchies that are holding the world
together so
it doesn't work
so something new for five dollars that's
what is the symbolism of soldiers
i'm a service member how can i best
understand meaning my profession
and the role i play and so i mean
soldiers are there to protect the
integrity
of what they're protecting whether it's
their nation
whether it's police practicing you know
protecting the integrity of cities or of
neighborhoods
or families that's the purpose of a
soldier is to protect
the integrity of things from outside
attack because
when there are different identities
sometimes the outside
of one identity is a potential for the
other
and so it's like your land is
potentially my land
and so you have to you have to somehow
protect the integrity of your land to
prevent me
from seeing you as just potential for me
as
food for me you know and so that's what
soldiers
do so mr highway for 99
cents sends me a banana peel nice
austin rush 499 says after watching
tenet i'm wondering if you see nolan
playing out the pattern of the saint
of his namesake
you glory be to god i never thought
about that
i have to think about it yeah tenet is
definitely interesting in terms of all
the whole symbolism of inversion and
and flips that we talk about and how
this kind of plays
with the world but it's yeah
i'm not sure it's totally coherent in
terms of
or not not tony cohen but but that it's
i'm not sure it exemplifies something
sure one of the things that exemplifies
is the capacity of the
of using the future to destroy the the
the present
that's an interesting idea you know
that's a different that's an interesting
idea if you think about things like
transhumanism
using the potential of the future to
destroy the present though intended you
have
some of that going on which is very
interesting
so kk item tag for 1999 usds happy
birthday in advance thank you
i was listening to the lord of spirits
and father stephen said a body was a
nexus of powers
which is only the church described as
the body of christ instead of the whole
creation in scripture
which is only the church described as
the body of christ instead of the whole
creation in scripture
and so you have to see it as these
nested realities
you know and so the tr so think about it
like um
think about it like so think about it
this way think about it like the church
is the body of christ but the church is
also something like
the priest of reality and so the church
acts
as a nation of priests which intercedes
for
all of creation and is also
participating
in the manner in which all of creation
can become
a nexus of powers for the
logos to be embodied in through
through the church and through and then
see it nested at different levels the
saints
act like that for us and then we with
the saints act like that for the whole
of reality uh you can see other levels
if you want but that's the best way of
understanding it
um so kyle hof for five dollars usd says
what did he mean by people can't tell
the difference between hybrids and
artificial beings
no no i didn't say uh hybrids and
artificial beings i said
the difference between hybrids and
synthetic beings
that is the difference between
okay so it's very simple and it's it's
very intuitive it's so
intuitive that you
some people might miss what i'm saying
how intuitive it is it's that
look at something can you say what it is
it's a dog it's a cat it's a lion
it's a human now look at something
and then you see it as a hybrid oh it's
not a human
it's a human mixed with a cat oh it's
not
a cat it's a cat mixed with a rabbit
that's a hybrid a hybrid is something
you can't identify with a category you
have to identify it with two categories
it's really very simple and so so
there's a way in which multiplicity
unites into unity
so it contains multiplicity right and so
you're a person you have
eyes and nose and a mouth you have all
this this multiplicity
but when i look at you i don't say well
that's an interesting mix of an
eyes nose and mouth i say no that's a
face i see a face
and so it's very intuitive but it's it's
a real experience there's a difference
between the experience of a being
that unites multiplicity into itself
into one
and a being that appears as a confusion
between two
identities
and i can't tell you when one when one
becomes the other because it's it's not
something that is
completely clear-cut uh you know and so
so so here's an
here's an example and so england
for let's say great britain for a while
is made out of celts and anglo-saxons
and
and and like saxons and angles and all
these different types of people
and so you have a sense in which at some
or
it's actually probably easier with the
french because the english still have
this idea that they're not completely no
no you could say that
that nonetheless there's a capacity they
have
to kind of maintain their own specific
identity but then nonetheless all appear
as british
and they can all kind of see themselves
as british they they're able to unite
their multiplicity
into one common identity and so there is
a way in which you can recognize a
british person
despite its multiplicity but you can
imagine that for a while it's just a
bunch of tribes fighting amongst each
other and kind of
you know competing for power and then
they didn't have
this unity and so it's like there was no
great britain it was just a mixture of
different of different tribes and then
at some point
things happened so that at some point it
joined together sufficiently that you're
able to see it
as one thing instead of a mixture of
things
i hope that makes sense but it's
important because it's like
if you want to reduce one of the
problems of our world
into one thing it's the incapacity
to tell the difference between a
synthetic being and a confused being
that's pretty much and or even and to
confuse one with the other
to think that multiplicity necessarily
means hybridization and mixture
and confusion and that that's good
but it's not good in itself there has to
be a balance between the two
right because obviously you can go x you
can be excessively one as well
but you need to find a balance between
unity and multiplicity
all right so the golden thread for ten
dollars what's the symbolism of me
enjoying drinks
and the mid-summer sunset while watching
the lightning bugs over pasture
and listening to quebecois
from this distributed symbol community
of symbologists
so i don't know with the i mean the
symbolism
of that i don't know it's a nice moment
it's the evening you're done your work
and you're allowed to enjoy some rest
and so hopefully
you you you feel like my my speaking for
you
at least is uh is not work that it's
kind of leisure um
so andrew komaromi for five dollars usd
says long time listener first time
caller thanks for your work
what do you think of meaning wave and
cure the dawn i like the scent exist one
with you
uh yeah i think akira don is great i
like i like what he does
i think i think he's uh i think he's
he's a i think he's a very intelligent
person and he's very
positive and i really appreciate that
about him and
uh and i think that i think in general
he's doing he's doing good things
and we're not completely aligned in
terms of our vision he's more on the
he's more on the kind of let's say
on the kind of more psychedelic side of
things and the more liberal
kind of that kind of stuff which is told
which is fine but i
i think that i think that what he's
doing is cool and i also really enjoyed
the the song he did the christmas song
he did about me
i was thinking one day that i should
have him on the channel um but i would
have to find something like i think we'd
have to find like a an angle to the
conversation
that would make sense to have them on
and so if you guys think of something
you can tell me maybe uh maybe it'll
prompt me to uh
to invite him
so symbolic memes says any comments on
father seraphim rose's critique
of the theory of evolution seeing it as
incompatible with the orthodox worldview
and so
i think i've kind of said what i need to
say about that which is that i think
that
the the description of the description
of um
the process of uh of selection and the
process of
uh you know that was described by darwin
i don't see a problem with that
like in terms of the actual process of
biological selection
uh the problem with evolution is the
narrative problem for me
it's like it's i i do feel like the
narrative of evolution the way it's
presented to us
is not compatible with the with the
orthodox
uh vision but i nonetheless feel like
it's not
it's still it's not talking about the
same thing the problem
is not that there are competing
scientific description in scripture
between scripture and evolution to
describe the world
it's rather that there's a there's a
competing
lens by which we look at the world one
which is a kind of
a kind of weird materialist you know uh
lens which is nonetheless trying to use
materialism to
to trace a story between millions and
millions of years i guess
it it it's it's very particular
uh and the
the the very the powerfully told story
the synthetic story which is told
in genesis which is by far superior and
by far
more useful to you as a person uh rather
than the other one
so i would say that i agree
with father seraphim in terms of in
principle i don't
i probably wouldn't have the exact same
approach as him um
just because we're also in a different
time but but i
i agree that it's that that's a story
it's not compatible
it's not compatible with us you can't
live in that story and if you do and you
you try to replace the story in genesis
with the story of evolution you try to
live in that story
yeah it's dark roads ahead you know but
i don't mind talking about
about about selection and about uh you
know
the the processes that were described by
darwin and then the people after him
all right so fred whedon man for ten
dollars says i'm in residential
construction and i'm wondering if you
could shed some light
on laying out the design of a home
specifically as a domestic church
so
i've talked about this quite a few times
in terms of you can understand a house
as a hierarchy of intimacy
it's probably the best way to understand
it and also
a kind of union of different purposes
into one whole and so it really is a
little microcosm
you know of of reality and it is very it
is similar to a church
um so you could think of uh
you can think of sorry a house having
something like a porch
or an entrance which is like the
vestibule or the narthex in the church
and then you have a common area which
would be like the diving
living room dining room which is uh
a place where you can have guests like
you know you encounter strangers on the
porch or at the end the entrance of your
house
you don't necessarily let them in uh and
the people you let in are people you
know better you are closer to it so you
have your friends
you have acquaintances into your living
room you have your good friends your
family at your dining room
where you me eat together and then you
have the intimacy with your
with your your husband or wife in the
bedroom which is not meant for strangers
and it's not even meant for your friends
people shouldn't go into your bedroom if
there's unless they i really have a
reason to it's it's odd to do that
um and so it's a it's a hierarchy of
intimacy is the best way to understand
it
um so the abc123456 gives another
20 usd to just right nofap gang so well
i'm happy
that you're in the nofap gang so ron
wood for 1999 hello jonathan have you
read far eastern folklore i've read some
and see a lot of symbolism
i understand but i also find some things
like the use of snakes in the legend of
tono of japan that i kind of play as
well
i don't know like i've read some but i
don't know
like i don't know that legend and i
don't know i don't know enough
but i once in a while i like to listen
to to kind of
other fairy tales from other countries
because they can cut sometimes come at
an angle that you don't expect and
surprise you um
so normative for 1999 brothers it is
later than you think hastened therefore
to do the work of god good encouragement
uh so the new guy 999 says what are your
thoughts on protestantism i know you've
expressed less than positive views
on it but want to know what your main
criticism are do you think of it as
false or confused christianity i just
said like late you probably weren't
listening at the beginning i said that i
want to try to stop constantly
criticizing protestantism
um but
i would say that that that that my basic
criticism
prosthetism is born in a revolutionary
the problem of revolution and how
revolution
removes legitimacy and and once you've
done that
then you're in trouble it's like i
always say that i agree with luther and
his criticism of the corrupt medieval
church and
the the uh the uh
the different abuses that were there uh
but as soon as as luther who wasn't a
bishop
and wasn't even a priest starts to name
priest
then i'm done with luther because you
can't give yourself authority
like actual you can say your opinion
like it's like i can give you my opinion
you know i can
i can say things but i don't
i can't
i can't lead you guys in a real way and
i don't want to that's why i keep
sending people to church
i'm like go to church don't don't don't
follow me
like you can like what i say and you can
agree with things i say
and it can kind of help you in your life
but i'm not your leader
and i don't want to be and if i was then
you should flee me
like a plague if i would try to be your
your leader or your like spiritual
leader or whatever
uh and so that's it like that's my
problem
um so michael o'connor for 20
said do you ever consider catholicism
because before he became orthodox and so
i did because i was from can't
from uh i'm french canadian and so i did
consider catholicism
before becoming orthodox but i felt like
uh i felt like uh
like it was it was coming i was leaving
the
kind of protestant church and then i
could see that the catholic church was
kind of coming towards the protestant
church in terms of his
the way that he was doing things um and
so
so it just didn't it just didn't die for
me i have friends who became traditional
catholics that were kind of in the same
meeting crisis as i was when i was
younger um
and they they seem happy there so
you know um
so i mean i have i i have respect for
for
serious catholics i have respect for all
serious christians it's like
you know i think you have to be careful
like when i'm also criticizing
different types of christianity that i
i think we have to be really careful
because
just because someone's orthodox doesn't
mean that
they can be just they could be a
horrible person and a horrible christian
and that's not just because you're
baptized and you go to a certain church
that it does
that it immediately gives you value you
know they're
they're very they're people that i would
that i would hesitate to criticize
in all the different denominations
because they
they embody they seem to embody
they seem to embody christ and so so
i have to be careful
so yeah so i think
so i think we're done guys 10 30.
so yeah so we got through this and so uh
so thanks everybody for your
attention thank you for your time
and so let me get one question from the
chat look at me i'm actually getting
questions from the chat
so jonathan can you samuel ramaleera
says can you explain briefly how the
consulting on symbolic world website
works
i'm actually not taking any consulting i
should probably remove that from the
website i'm actually not taking any more
consulting contracts
just because i'm really overwhelmed with
everything
so um so yeah so i'm not doing that
so anyway so it was good to talk to
everybody and i will see you all
next month thanks for your attention and
i'll talk to you very soon bye-bye